[Музика]
так заздрить Colima wt7
фотосистема людина з Китаю - більш
завзятий Kalia відео індивідуальний сенатор
Мендоза Кабо гепард зоряний корабель Скалія
тепер принаймні давай зроби няню Кохутту
Мішель Бачелет, яка не знає, що
він підходить до того ж  що таке гусак
quali pastino картопляна рампа, яку я скромно любив e tomu crunch
keep it general
disarray marina - :
привіт всім я сподіваюся, що у вас все
дуже добре, привіт наші дорогі гості, це
я знову мене звати Олена і ми маємо
уроку англійської мови в п'ятому
році немає, але ви бачили раніше -
vittala або nasarah можуть, будь ласка, підійти до
демократії, тому хлопці перше, що потрібно зробити,
це перевірити те, що ви вже знаєте, тому
ми проведемо невеликий тест так, давайте назвемо
це так, як ви  буде читати
твердження, і ваше завдання полягає в тому, щоб показати нам
правду чи неправду,
тому ви повинні вирішити,
правдиве це твердження чи хибне, добре,
так що підняття у мене буде істиною, а
яйце буде мати неправду добре добре ідеальна
командна робота добре  ми почнемо, а потім ми
будемо говорити про ці речі
детально, так, але зараз ми просто перевіряємо
те, що ви вже знаєте або, ймовірно, не
знаєте, так, давайте зробимо це, я підніму, і
я можу почати, будь ласка, перше, так
ураган  це дуже сильний вітер, і це
правда, це правда, звичайно, добре Алек
посуха посуха посуха - це ненормальна
кількість води я не знаю, ти не
знаєш, що ти думаєш, Джо мм-хм
саме
бідний, так що хот-дог і він каже  посуха -
це ненормальне явище, що означає ненормально
багато води, якщо вона суха, чи
є у нас вода,
ні, так вона падає
добре посуха Заза я дивлюся, як гнобитель нудьги,
хто б це не
притиснув, Ровіра добре,
я жив у сусідньому  одна повінь - це може бути
безперервний період сухої погоди, це
помилкова повінь - це те, що генерал Боуден
Бхаван, напевно, знає, що називається кип'ятінням,
було б достатньо. Продюсер - Ібака - так,
це зовсім не сухо
складні запитання
Це правда, так, тому що землетрус
може бути під водою, так, на
дні океану, наприклад, і
саме так цунамі коштують дуже добре, ви
дуже розумні, а який з них залишився,
торнадо НАТО не має нічого спільного з
повітрям, оскільки воно  неправда, тому що торнадо
викликається повітрям, звичайно, це повітряний
стовп так, крутиться, звичайно, це
має багато спільного з повітрям, і якщо ми
говоримо про цунамі, то це цунамі
це велика хвиля, це правда чи неправда так,
це правда,
ви  re дуже розумний тепер ви повинні бути
досить розумні, щоб вгадати, як
називається тема, тому ми почали говорити
про ці природні речі, і
є термін, який пояснює і може означати, що це
таке, так, тому ми повинні написати тему
урок у вас є три удари так
три спроби вгору нижня карта над
T три Разіель питання було Вася поїздка
взяти бомбу ми продовжуємо досягти Bugatti я
повинен побачити маленьке ім'я я
повільно мотиватор поганий або нормальний висвітлення
бутик літературний g  iver Vijaya the
most beautifui 10 e ee w no oh hey a
yeah
ладно, так що тобі пощастило, у мене є три
літери правильно T it TZ або ggg-good це
природно перше слово натуральний молодець
і природний що це може бути, якщо ви думаєте
про все  ті у справі, так, але як
ви називаєте це англійською, коли
щось не так, панове, так, так, у вас
ще залишилося багато бомб, так, і у нас
не було великого вибуху, що
дійсно добре,
чудова робота Dabra Oranje природні катаклізми
ви були абсолютно праві чи
можете ми прочитати слова будь ласка, але чи можете
ви прочитати цю колонку та підняття я
прочитаю ті слова, які
є праворуч чи можете ви прочитати ті, будь ласка,
повінь повінь повінь повінь що таке
звіт про повінь, ймовірно, немає вулканічного
вулкана два слова  разом виверження
вулкану, тому ми маємо колодязь я думаю, що
блискавка, що таке блискавка,
тому іноді це дуже страшно, міс
Кафка, піхва Луїзи Кафки, блискавка, так,
торнадо, торнадо, торнадо, торнадо, така жила на
Алясці, лісова пожежа
ні, я маю на увазі  sunami вантажівка zessica
він quake, ймовірно, не автомобіліст, і
тепер ми повинні зіставити слова з
малюнками так, так це має виглядати так,
що ми бачимо хутряну
картину, ми бачимо блискавку, а
ця машина дуже темна і багато
хмар  так, то що це за
блискавка урагану, вони дуже близькі, коли
я роблю cheb Liske Rohan
booyah Iblees кашель, оптична хвороба, сестра,
кожен предмет має так багато про
блискавки урагану.
Дивіденди Ванесси або ніколи не враховують,
що один лісова пожежа, очевидно,
цунамі  це дуже велика хвиля так, у
нас в Україні цунамі не може бути,
тому що у нас є море, але я не
пам'ятаю, а ви використовуєте про цунамі,
слава Богу, у нас не було,
і я сподіваюся, що у нас не буде  добре
flood кипіння англійської встановлює
складку в попередньому коді vu черепа
нирки груди новий зелений дозування наша
плита і навіть карта вгору О, що це
викликано тим, що ви думаєте, що вона
перша станція і велика кількість
води  я люблю цей світ, мабуть,
тропічна вирубка лісів і кольори, дуже
бутанське резюме логічне, мабуть,
не дуже розумна дівчина добре така інша
станція і через вирубку лісів та
деякі інші природні речі дуже часто у нас
є недоліки, тому що йде сильний дощ, так
і у нас багато води  добре, повернути стрілку
торнадо Беккі Будда і землетрус
їх правда, тоді майстер правди почнеться
просто Крізі бу плаче від обережності, як
шляхта вбиває Елізабет Русев, попереджує мене в
основному, але коли земля трясеться,
так, і це може завдати шкоди
будівлям, і це дуже  небезпечно
так добре, ви можете спробувати прочитати слова, які
вони трохи перемішані спочатку
так, другий перший пожежа лісова
пожежа приятель по дзюдо Шаттак
позиція лісової пожежі можливо побачити цунамі та
цунамі відновлюються виглядати мені подобається назва
землетрус землетрус пережовує
землетрус і  останнє
переривання або виверження вулкана, це
правильно,
добре, це маленька гра, це
як змії та леті  rs, але на ньому не
було зображення змії та літери,
тому це виглядатиме так, тому ми просто
повинні кинути кубик, так,
і ми будемо рахувати картинки, і
все, що вам потрібно зробити, це
просто назвати  назва цього стихійного
лиха добре,
а також у нас є кілька стрілок три, щоб
ви могли дивитися на них, тому, коли ви туди,
наприклад, ви піднімаєтеся, так, або якщо ви йдете вниз
, ви пересуваєте на одну коробку далі, добре,
ми не збираємося грати  протягом багатьох років ми
побачимо, як це працює для нас добре, так ви
хочете кинути кістки так добре, ви можете
зловити так один добре, так один це той,
який це це
блискавка так і коли це трапиться
добре добре добре  шторм - це ти
в день, так, коли погода
штормова добре,
твоя черга добре, так що ти повинен рахувати
від штормової корми, це значить, була буря, а
потім один до того, що з будівлею
ні, я маю на увазі це  один, і ви переміщаєте
це, тому вам потрібно назвати цей, а
потім ви рухаєтеся вниз, щоб о  не полягає в
тому, що зверху ви можете побачити будівлі та
багато водних споруд Каліф Сельваджі
називає Deutsche ba ha балакучість
як монтаньоса діамо намалюйте те, що так, щоб
це було плоским, а тепер ви рухаєтеся до
цієї картини, так, що це
за торнадо Tyrande, дуже розумне, добре
дай кубик своєму другові
п'ять п'ять добре, один два три чотири п'ять,
і ти підеш, так,
ти назвав цей, а потім той,
так що це за цунамі цунамі і чи можеш
ти піти лісова пожежа лісова пожежа добре,
я дозволю тобі черзі п'ять
давайте порахуємо разом один два три чотири
п'ять останнє зображення це торнадо
торнадо, звичайно, добре, і давайте зробити ще
два обороти, можливо, так, я послухав, а
потім знову ви, і все, тому що ми
можемо грати вічно
п'ять п'ять давайте порахуємо один два три чотири
п'ять
ага, це  тітонька оратор дружина знову
улюблений номер один два три чотири п'ять
який повінь добре що це правильно
цей це малюнок Браун дуже суха
посуха так, а це один погляд
на будинок це ураган  e
точно землетрус, так що один заряд,
так, а як щодо цього, ви можете
побачити гору, вулкан і лаву, що
йде від нього виверження виверження або
виверження вулкана дуже добре добре, так що деякі
питання, що це за речі, у вас
є невелике поле зі словами  ураган
землетрус посуха блискавка повінь так, чи
можете ви прочитати по черзі та розповісти нам, що
це означає, тож ви повинні вибрати один
варіант зі слова Bank я живу сьогодні,
ви можете почати, можливо, перший
тихе сильне потрясіння землі його
землетрус землетрус  Звичайно, Елліот
порадує шторм сильними,
що означає, що це ураган,
звичайно, так що це магазин, але це
дуже, дуже страшно, дуже сильно
і дуже важко,
молодець, довго, коли не
вистачає дощу, посуха посуха
для друга  велика кількість води - це
повінь, звичайно, і останній -
раптове яскраве світло в небі, коли
є шторм, це
блискавка, яку ви також мали
фотографії  Ви думаєте, що ви повинні допомогти
вам добре, я щось дуже схожий на
цей,
тож що ми думаємо про це, у
нас виверження блискавки, землетруси,
квітка та посуха, тож давайте прочитаємо
речення, і ми спробуємо використати ці
слова в контексті  добре, минулої неділі ми
не могли вийти на вулицю, всюди була вода
, уявіть собі, що ви
намагаєтеся вийти на вулицю, але все інше
так, це під водою, тому в нашій країні це була повінь,
у людей дуже
міцні будівлі, тому що у нас
часто відбуваються землетруси  землетрус Японія, можливо,
так, минулого літа погода була дуже спекотною,
тому що не було дощу,
була посуха посуха, дивіться, ви
пам’ятаєте слова, які вже добре, наступне, яке я
бачив по телевізору минулого вчора, було
виверження вулкана на острові
в  Тихий океан і гаряча лава зійшла
з вулкана, так, це зрозуміло, тому що
тільки коли відбувається виверження вулкану,
гаряча лава виливається з вулкана,
і остання моя молодша сестра
афра  ідентифікатор блискавки, тож коли йде
сильна буря, вона завжди ховається, вона
завжди ховається
зазвичай виглядає красиво, ми розуміємо, що
це дуже небезпечно, так, але все одно це
виглядає дивовижно,
але грім дуже лякає, але він
збирається разом, так, так, вони
партнери, вони збираються разом добре, тому
це лише для наших студентів, щоб переглянути
та перевірити, так і я  думаю, що ми
правильно відповіли на всі ці запитання,
і ми зробили це так добре, і чи є
у вас спінер, який зробив спінер, гм, у мене не
було шансу купити звичайний, але
все одно я дам вам цей спінер,
так що це наш спінер  і ви можете
бачити різні сегменти, кожен сегмент
має стихійне лихо, тому ви розкручуєте його,
а також у вас буде кілька слів, щоб
підтримати вас, наприклад, якщо ми говоримо
про це цунамі, це велика хвиля, тому
ви маєте  скласти речення, два
чи три речення, вирішувати вам. Я знаю,
що ви розумні, і ви можете це зробити
перший вибір, що в ньому сказано, чи можете ви
скласти речення або якщо хочете, ви
можете просто дати визначення повені,
або ви можете скласти речення, або ви можете
створити історію зараз, це залежить від
вас колись цей хлопчик  на ім'я Ед,
він вийшов зі свого дому, і
раптом на вулиці була повінь, тому
що багато днів було занадто сильний дощ,
добре, тож чи міг він вийти на вулицю чи
йому довелося залишитися вдома,
йому потрібен човен, щоб поїхати  надворі - добре
Алекс, поверніть добре лісові пожежі величезні RS добре
величезні території, що це означає величезна площа
величезні території величезні означає величезний гігант великий
великий deucey deucey maliki місцеві запаси
заткніть пацієнта і хапайте нас, тому що на
нього крокомірні зонди, можливо, бачать
територію Willa Chesney багато  опустіть своє
запитання для Марші  - Тара Амма, нехай це
не так, якщо ви живете в лісі в
лісі, так, спочатку і ви вже
розумієте, що ви під поворотом, що перша пожежа почалася мм-хм, ви розумієте, що пожежа починається лісова пожежа.
ви можете так швидко, тому що це
буде пожежа величезні помилки
величезні площі будуть спалені
математично величезні площі лісу будуть
спалені, звичайно, і це дуже
небезпечно, тому що все відбувається
дуже швидко, так, так, це починається лише з
одного дерева і  потім він поширюється по
всьому лісу, так, і він може поглинати його, може
спалити величезні території, добре зроблено
наступний землетрус, коли я
подорожував, і я прокинувся
вночі в моєму готелі, тому що моє ліжко
тремтіло, і я зрозумів, що це  був
землетрус, тому що
зі мною також трапилося землетрусу, було так страшно
посеред ночі, і я не
знав, що робити,
так, це дуже страшно мм-хм добре
цунамі велика хвиля мм-хм я знаю, що це
виглядає  цунамі  це дуже глибоко, дякую
дуже глибоко під водою, земля
трясеться, трясеться,
так і землетрус відбувається або трапляється,
і після цього землетрусу у нас це так,
так, але це абсолютно
правильно, добре зроблено, можливо, ще один добре,
це не буря ні багато, так зазвичай ми
у горах багато снігу,
і саме взимку,
особливо взимку, у нас може бути навіть
снігова буря мм-хм
, це, звичайно, добре для перших лиж, але це також
може бути дуже небезпечно так, добре,
ми зробили з цим і збираємося  щоб
переглянути прості терміни минулого минулого, ми
повинні поговорити про події в
минулому, так, і що ми повинні пам'ятати,
що у нас є звичайні дієслова вчителі
без проблем, а неправильні дієслова ми зберігаємо
солодку ймовірність' go-go-go bottom a pro
regular  дієслова досить Kipnis проблема ви
покажете мені демонстраційне шоу ви можете сказати kimchi
kolene amputee eg seduce aleko it shampoo
kapoor ashima вибір вузький модульним
поділом коли-небудь перетнув мій не
їв лапу Тоня зробила дозвіл напр.
Служба відновлена, ви впевнені,
що проблема все ще створюється, тому ми маємо
таблицю, про яку всі знають, і ви
повинні заглянути в цю таблицю, щоб дізнатися
слова так, вологість Ніка формують
абсолютне ім’я Мері, коли ви
натискаєте на Мію, яку навчають зараз  попередній код подивіться
бюджетні форми Roca за допомогою пилки в
Midsomer Shabazz Napier Шеф-кухар Том Робін
із Sita bleached не знав
негативних речень те ж саме, що ми використовували,
не так,
а для запитання, яке ми використовуємо, робив, коли ми
використовуємо, не знав і зробив  ми не говоримо, тому ми
говоримо, подивіться після цього так, що відбувається у
вашому стовпці часу, але
це не стосується угоди, але з часом я
сказав колишній infinity vobis - я
не буду оптимізувати яйцеклітину Jinnah Bucharest,
щоб більше над моїм  домовися, щоб дати мені
Кевін о так, поговори добре,
що важливо для нас, у нас є ці
важливі слова, які допомагають нам зрозуміти,
що ми говоримо про події
в минулому, і що нам потрібно використовувати цей
дуже напружений час, який
ти цілував, побачиш Славу вчора, Джора
востаннє  тиждень Abba минулого року Manolo Hitoshi
Manolo Heroku дві години або два дні або
два місяці тому розділив Nieto настрій
місіс.  suitum перевага новий Томо в квітні
NAPLAN Куомо фільм жахів економіка
крамольна Тереза і в 1996
оці в приквелі Віаком є Д'Амброзіо дещо з
Лі Толандом на стрічці минулого прост
добре, а тепер у нас буде части
а для читання, і ми будемо говорити  про дикі
місця та деякі подорожі, так, тому у нас
є три невеликих тексту, ми збираємося
їх прочитати, і ви будете звертати
увагу на слова, як я
їх позначив для вас, так,
але це вірно, Тата намалює, кого
більше Ісус залишить бхакті Міленка  домашні тварини
CUNA добре, коли hola muchachas давай,
ти можеш прочитати, будь ласка, перший минулого
літа я їздив до Гімалаїв,
це були робочі канікули, і ми
багато працювали кожен день, це був дивовижний
досвід, тому це було так, хоча було
дуже небезпечно бути там  було багато
снігу і ми боялися сніжних бурів
снігові бурі перш за все який словниковий запас
ми маємо з нашої теми no stone snow
storm небезпечні укуси nabis не поклонятися
див. стихійні лиха небезпечні doc
Shyam
літо мм-хм  m добре, що щодо минулого
часу які форми пішли
ймовірність немає проблем і проблема,
що було питання проблема була
знову робота була пройдена
що щодо це проблема документ, але
переміщення каже резюме ela обіцяю, незалежно від
його відходу mm  мм мм о, давайте візьмемо
наступне минулого літа в липні я їздив
на Гаваї в липні минулого літа в липні я
їздив до США, чи це долина Уолл-е
через Долину Смерті
Метт, що ми не знаємо,
що це багато часу  в сумо в Сполучених
Штатах добре, це називається так, тому що цей
регіон дуже сухий, там майже не вижило жодної рослини,
оскільки немає води
мм-хм, це дощ, де рідко, це було
рідко, кажуть так, тому не часто, але
вона робить  нам ідіот добре
мм-хм,
влітку було спекотно, і
через посуху взагалі не було планів
, а температура була у нас 45
градусів, ммм,
перші європейці називали європейців
людьми з Європи, які приїхали туди,
але першими європейцями мм-  хм, ф  Перші
європейці закликали до Долини Смерті,
тому що там було так сухо і без води
не було можливе життя. GW дав
нам bully stemis labarda Давічі
Окаяма літо літо так суха вода
що робить що я пережив виживання
це через природні катаклізми am  я
закінчую - Триша і жарко
з нашого останнього уроку
саме скрипка жорстка смачна піко
наток шеф-кухар знає нижче посуха вуса
Лі Тюк вода немає життя добре так чому
ця долина називається Долиною смерті
- Лена Мері Мартін тому
що щось там щось не живе так
нічого нічого там нічого подібного
тому що що що є
причина тому тому що дуже сухо
так причина тому, що
дуже сухо і є  немає води
, тому рослини просто не можуть
вижити там  Dalia нерегулярний був
звичайний я був там, де знову був і
холодний звичайний звичайний одяг і
одяг так, Кодама ніколи не втрачав мій дядько
поїхав до Південної Америки минулого літа, це
був чудовий відпочинок,
він зробив красиві фотографії, він хотів
побачити виверження вулкана, але там  was
no
we have akay подивіться словник літня робота
над виверженням вулкана виверження точно і
що щодо минулого часу go was
irregular take irregular хотів був
завжди та хотів регулярний добре
і останнє завдання для вас це виглядає трохи
великим, але я обіцяю, що останнє
все, що вам потрібно зробити, це перевірити, як
ви знаєте неправильні дієслова так, тому ми
зробимо це разом, якщо ви не пам’ятаєте
деякі з них, добре, тож давайте прочитаємо текст,
і у вас є слова, які слід
поставити в минуле  проста форма добре добре
хм ну ви починаєте добре Ого, ми мій хуліган,
нам так пощастило вчора, яку
дивовижну погоду ви бачили як шторм
минулої ночі, ми не пропустили повідомлення в
Давос, небо виглядало дуже незвичайним, це було
це був перший раз, коли я побачив небо таким,
що мені сподобалося, номер два Оскар, це
почалося близько восьмої години, і спочатку
я подумав, що це неправда, хоча це
не буде ще один рух сьомий момент,
коли позначка я  Треба бути простим, так,
це було не так погано, але
незабаром почався сильний дощ, і
дощ йшов десять годин
мм-хм так, я був так наляканий, коли
побачив блискавку і почув грім
під нею  так голосно мм-хм
, було дуже вітряно, я, мабуть,
залишився вдома
сьогоднішня погода
чудова, і я можу повірити, що тільки
вчора я бачив бурю, як той
Трюдо з амілоїдом, дивіться, що момо-сама бідність,
давайте Евклід досягає майже всього
прем'єра океанів на лаві підсудних, тому я позначив
усі дієслова тут червоним,
так, щоб ви могли бачити, що деякі з них є
регулярними, деякі з них неправильні, тож
ви можете просто подивитись на це ще раз,
ви дійсно мій відмінник,
дуже дякую, док  хвиля, схоже, розвинулась,
масова аудиторія сказала, що бюджет
пара  of douches review Клеомен
поставив хлопців у 30 інтерактивних у для мого
це вище йети класу гімнастка Вела
Бхай до Еріка навіть потрапив у машину з морозивом
так я перестаю ще я побачив би їх,
коли я це просте додавання кореневі
цифри  економіка хороша Падуя, шоу
символ спокою Обами для моєї команди, коли Ебола
Перрі Я збираюся виправити, чому це буде розвиватися
на тому, що прихід може просто знати
Кашіа Ді Маджіо Абуду без Міяко
Каватина внесок
Медузи Арізона Латиноамериканка, щоб хтось він
кричав до мене  sure yaha - Fiesta
Sabu обмежений стиліст a yaja dollars
[Музика]
ви